tell Extreme Masters champions
majors back-to-back
[Applause]
[Music]
guys what a major we witnessed the
coronation of the one true unchallenged
gods of counter-strike in a straw --less
we saw a mean become reality as ents
made the grand finals over the likes of
Team Liquid and Navi there were moments
that made us want to stand up the screen
moments that warmed our hearts and there
were moments that made us laugh and
maybe cringe just a little bit and
that's why we've got a fails in funny
moments of the major coming up for you
in less than 24 hours right here right
now we're only talking about the good
[ __ ] the aces the clutches the
game-winning match defining moments that
make majors magical and of course the
out of game moments that made this
particular event so special now let's
get this video started with the best
aces and clutches from IEM katowice 2019
the tried and tested it is go to your
cast all that hit shot for me and he's
picking up more than gives Greyhound a
great chance to cut was no plant yet
that might be a bit early for Dick Stacy
but he's gonna find the kill missed shot
from Flushing and a beautiful follow up
second one automatic Goes Down and it's
the rookie everything to do and he's
delivering a war on two and greyhounds
slows down the retake truly is a baptism
of fire for Celsus already picked up
three sterling and Malta remain and he's
spidey senses are tingling he's gonna
pick up another headshot consensus
feasibly pull this one off it's all down
to Sterling whittling away the time kid
but it doesn't matter South is with a
beautiful coach I think that's good I
think we have that already I'm real sure
we get like fallen looking all smoldery
with a head so on
most shot from Mexico it doesn't connect
pressure on long and he does manage to
thrive with it once again connects on to
cell so I think he's found its nemesis
been take now on the side sports flash
and that's gonna be analog on the floor
this could get bad fast effects carrots
doesn't move quickly he's in a terrible
position if they start going white is no
one to support him he finds one and how
escapes through the smoke make control
yet again here from straws they're gonna
try to fight through the small
thoughtfully finding one can't get a
third gratis factions gonna end that
streak before it even begins astralis
taking control amid yet again and I'm
I'm not gonna lie I would have been
wrong with Michael as well because two
people were in the a sight instead of
just one we've tried to go be time and
time again and it's if X is just there
to destroy you and device we'll be
losing this op battle now we have a
little bit of a round on our hands just
about 45 seconds left on the clock disc
set up there in sandwich but yes you're
right they cats need to find that frag
in fact Rattus faction will be the one
that does find it first and foremost in
the round now turning in the way of the
renegades the bomb will be planted jks
gratis faction and lee s to defend this
plants in fact trying to get sneaky does
find the kill and aleeah's but he will
be cut down by the awp of gratis faction
now to pre the renegades yeah I cannot
believe he got the sandwich kill it
takes some surreal cojones to jump over
into sandwich like that John does a lot
of Kahuna Street
hey hey done yet Hey
so there's surely never going to expect
dead Fox and this is where the HP on
automatic remember he hasn't pick a
damage from an opponent it's all been a
teammate automatics gonna be a free kill
but it'll also give things out for us
I'll know exactly what's gonna happen
actually the trigger discipline this is
amazing he's got to be careful rush not
aware of great round from dead Fox get
right in let grow both charging straight
in with tilts at their own it's a
complete chaos night Matt right now for
vici they're losing players left and
right Black Crowes gonna go down to the
hands of Freeman leaving Jeff right once
again in the 1b to clutch he's taking
one of them down but only has eight HP
to play with the time is on his side for
the finale it's gonna go for that bomb
plant gonna force it down put Freeman
into a position where he needs to push
him
will the 8hb be enough for Freeman the
coaches around you can see what it means
to him they should be able to trade this
one out Coulter I'm not pretty enough
Multi Frank position but he's getting it
done is making it work as he gets three
kills taka will back him up and his
fantastic work by him they didn't expect
him to be in the open like that most CT
setups are very passive and lucky is
anything but and that's Lou goes down to
the one bus his one he knows where taco
is as well he knows he's stuck inside of
the pit at this point in time he could
back off he has the ball he wants taco
to have that shadow of doubt in his mind
that he's already left he's gonna walk
out lucky pulls it back brilliantly
Aleksey be somehow clauses one back
single-handedly he's gonna get caught up
from a tent and surely at this point
though the author there's a little bit
of damage to boo Mitch Sergey vo WP left
alone now three verses one short least
where we see them get around the board
if he gets the bomb denied oh my
goodness yes here's a chance
this is unbelievable that is so sick
from Sergei how he keeps that round
alive for the team I have no idea
symbols already over there he's behind
his Smokey's falling off that may not be
true when the guns are brought out but
for now it certainly is the first kill
though go is the way a flaming he
already has the pistol it's just enough
to cut off one of the retake but the
bomb already planted for Navi and they
just have to hold it off that's not hard
flame he's got another it's gonna be
extremely difficult they're simple can
get around from coffins without being
spotted
blue boxes preoccupied if he wraps in
they're both gone for neo and they're
gonna push it all together brain can't
do enough just to neat go third of the
world last year but he's got a to a
one-on-one bones team that's got a sling
they know that blamey what a pistol an
ace he gets an ace welcome to spotting
everybody just waiting for it bit back
and forth wants to figure out the side
I'll enter into paper to Nico but Nico
go on it's now all on to its rent so
proficient with the pistol but you know
who is a man who got an ace last time
he's got to idiot the only two for Navi
so far flamey as the bomb gets planted
inside of B Olaf's gonna take the long
rotation the flank from behind Zeus is
watching it
it's Guardian that wants rain to work
with him so he can get in from ruin so
he can take some of the attention away
to skip it up
Zeus saw in cleared banana he hat dole
off was in behind the wall they're gonna
think that's wide open but now they
realize with the other kills they've all
turned around flame he's looking for
double ace in the pistol double ace in
the bezel both of them ten kills two
pistols two rounds for Navi and there's
no grenades even they'd love to throw
balls whole debacle one of these angles
all chewy uncharacteristically comes
outside confessing the trade and it's
not a twist again they know exactly
where he is
shot three pick from twists or sub just
this map is warming up it's not gonna be
a one-sided affair hopefully we go the
full distance and see you can hold their
own is simple
we'll be native down to 35 the audacity
to stick around and face off for it
flamie chimes in with the third at 5:00
buzz is two out of nowhere
unreal that simples found two of those
already in this series five HP as well 4
X 7 simple once more because he does all
he's got to do though is keep firing
speculative shots because here we go
words and see the more you - because now
it's only a one-man advantage simple is
being dynamic as ever discuss the angle
as well watch sergey because he's gonna
walk straight into it simple he'll shut
down self even a pegboard couldn't fit
and finish the flank simple will do it
all
Max Evans opened up the a sight though
he's wide open here flame he's over with
simple on B so fall plant certainly as a
possibility simple wants to get the
optic catch him Sam 7 to try and
completely catch them all now he was
trying to save anyone's rotating respawn
and just giving someone a bomb pitch but
he's had not already one bus is one
against the orb HP no longer a fact that
you can see when it's round it doesn't
connect no one has the flower he's gotta
go those simple he's got the gun back up
simples close enough for HP pistol holds
it off device still waits his mother
they wrote him back off Nikki time
mister he's got x7 down does he expect
he won't aerial knew it and it's on
cynics again but this time he's got a
little more than a C's ed this is the
problem though when zip Xperience clear
he's up to no good they know he's on B
but where are they possibly get that
information they'll go together that is
the right call but this time keep in
mind also there's no kids yes indeed I'm
no smoke zipping could just be patient
and let noise reveal all so he didn't
see it he didn't realize his own gun I
think block the vision and now cippec's
knows that they're working in one above
Ollie's the lamb slaughter now those
were some incredible plays but it's the
major guys what do you expect now not
every godlike highlight is going to be
an ace or a clutch and that's why we've
got the best of the rest of vac worthy
plays from the major an eco primed for
another one only seen a couple of
aggressive plays addressed by the
flashback is spot on he's done so much
damage at two kills make it three go his
way pop flash speed perfection and
against those ak-47s could be deadly
next step for an IP you can see
systematically taking map control first
in halls kaze catches force at a jump
eco going in first with the scout
channel and some majestic shots but it's
not gonna be enough to yield around more
than likely
it's looking fantastic 4G - and lucky
who finds the bomb no time remaining X
group actually takes an aide to the face
and sure he could be traded out at this
point they even waive the time to expire
there is a flank coming here I think it
was a cell first
that's a spirit heard it can he very
isolated on quad all by his lonesome
yeah I mean look how easy it is just
take mid control especially on the piste
around you apply just a little bit of
pressure and sharks doesn't want to
commit to that fight a long way for him
to fall back and Chan are so close
there's the shadow showing one tap from
shocks and now the offense it's not
finding any success Kenny and the
bombsite always answering our questions
now we doubted him but what an
impressive start Shox and Kenny yes
those were the two names we discussed
and here they are
what's that Molotov clears vitality will
start to move in they're still waiting
for
Alexson RPK to get round from CT side
which are doing right now they do have a
smoke which has just been tossed out in
three flash banks
the downside is no hate cheese or
Molotov sin/cos a he's able to claim
first blood they lie not but it's a
freeman against the clock vici you've
actually pulled that two before clutch
out of the hats it's not the pincer
round towards heaven so you can get
round the back of ramp if he can sir
could be a goner he hasn't quite got it
to close enough proximity races really
playing this one perfectly
these are nice survive as long as
possible see how many players you can
line up either fly them two sprays both
down res flawless play smoked out now
when I say that was summer he's gone the
bomb started to cross now but I look at
this they're actually what
the destruction slack's is going it
somebody now it's not another one with
the orc to finish it forest
dream on flashback able to lease a claim
within but res he's playing this one so
slowly he is waiting for his many
terrorists to push past him as possible
but in doing so he's baiting the rest of
his teammates can he feasibly stop this
forest
I thought Reza painted too hard but he
pulls it back this is the CT side astral
is known for this half
they're very dominate here the real
question will be is nine rounds enough
for the Renegades here they already try
to contest ramp early on in those
headshots the bikes cannot blaze that
too low on that note gonna have a much
better time after that pistol you can
see in the mini-map you have a guide
towards the 8th bump side make sure
nobody pushes he's going for the recipe
not hitting it though but it gives them
a lot of information that you have on a
VPS watch the bebop side that's why they
comfortably can take middle out having
it though yeah comfortable the strong
word when simples in the server double
and I think a trip home my goodness oh
baby a triple in this time for a player
squeaky dual mall itself to start the
push to start you don't like to see that
but all of this damage and well they've
read it to perfection check hey s with
the peak of a lifetime on a device
punish him
don't let us in the frost off zooming
towards insiders since
[Applause]
alright then fully blind trying to bait
out a shot from the off and over there
or finally it is actually there's gonna
be a chance for two players good on
Vince you might be eating another boot
tamson waiting in the bombsite oh okay
nice that is cruel and unusual and round
peek out towards CT flash goes over oh
yes sir what sadist damn sexy from
[Music]
because it's simple over toward B pulls
back after the first season long
slipshod Cavallari tries to beat it
again and he will he absolutely will
strike through the lens simple finds
around again nothing okay guys so far
we've seen plays that got our hearts
racing but we also wanted to show you
the moments that warmed our hearts as
well and this major had more than its
fair share well this week or at this
event to Intel Extreme Masters champion
suffered a personal tragedy one player
lost his father
one player lost his mother but they
chose to be here because in order to be
the best they had to be here this week
not next week not the week after that
they have to be here this week in order
to be the best they chose to stay
because together with other people they
were chasing the same dream and they
chose not to fail those people
now I don't know I have no idea what it
takes to do what they did I can't
possibly imagine but I wanted to take
this opportunity why I'm here on stage
to honor their sacrifice because what
they did is what champions do now all
the players here they committed their
entire lives to be here this week and be
the best version of themselves this week
when you watch them when you watch them
compete
please remember please think of all the
possible sacrifices that they made in
order to be here I wish all of you that
this major is the best major of all time
the most entertaining week that you've
ever had in your lives and that when you
go home please remember to tell your
father and tell your mother that you
love them thank you
I came into this tournament with my
father now he passed away just before
got here and his last wish was that I I
went here and so I really wanted this
well guys that about does it for the
best from IEM katowice 2019 three weeks
of incredible counter-strike and I can't
believe we have to wait till September
to do it all again but if you're still
craving that major content well in less
than 24 hours we'll be dropping the best
fails and funny moments from this major
as well so I'll see you then thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]